voici le moment où un missile russe a
frappé ce marché fréquenté de l'est de
l'Ukraine
et voici les conséquences de l'attaque
une dizaine de morts et des magasins des
états les cafés réduits Ensemble
grâce à Dieu nous sommes en vie mais les
vendeuses qui travaillaient ici sont
mortes instantanément une fille et un
enfant sont mordre les vifs l'enfant
était petit
nous avons failli être touchés on vient
toujours ici faire nos courses
heureusement pour nous nous avons décidé
d'y aller plus tard aujourd'hui la
frappe avait déjà eu lieu le président
zellinski a condamné cette frappe sur
caution tinifca qu'il décrit comme
abominable et délibéré
à chaque fois qu'il y a une avancée dans
la contre-offensive ukrainienne les
Russes prennent pour cible les civils et
les infrastructures civiles ils
choisissent des cibles que leur missile
et leur artillerie peuvent attendre
nous connaissons bien cette zone nous
savons que cette frappe était délibérée
d'après les autorités ukrainiennes c'est
la pirataque qui est touché le pays
depuis des mois quotient dans la région
du Dombasle tout près de la ligne de
front elle se situe à seulement 27 km de
barmut théâtre de combats intense entre
force de Kiev et armée russe le
procureur général ukrainien a annoncé
l'ouverture d'une enquête sur cette
attaque condamnée par washing